Lots of people seem to think that I’m not real.
Apparently I’m AI generated! Maybe it’s true!
There’s a lot of talk about how artificial
intelligence is going to change the world
in the coming years. A lot of jobs that
people do today will probably disappear,
and a lot of the skills that we
think are important to learn will
probably become irrelevant, because
AI will be better at them than humans.
How about the skill of being able
to speak another language? Will it
become irrelevant? In some ways it probably will.
You didn’t know I was fluent
in Turkish, did you? Actually,
I’m not. That wasn’t me speaking Turkish.
That was AI. I was speaking English and the
AI tool translated it into Turkish. Let’s see that
again - and pay attention to how my mouth moves.
You can see that the AI tool is producing
a Turkish translation in my own voice,
and it even controls the movements of my mouth to
make it look like it’s really me that’s speaking.
The specific tool that I’m using is
called HeyGen. The way it works is
that you can upload a video of yourself and
it translates it into a different language.
You get the point. I’m sure the results are not
perfect, but they seem pretty good. If you’re a
native speaker of Turkish, Chinese, or German,
what do you think of the translation? Does it
seem authentic, or at least pretty good?
Let us know in the comments down below.
So, this AI tool doesn’t translate
your speech in real time - you need
to first record a video of yourself, then
upload it and the tool will translate it.
So it’s useful if you want to create
an on-demand video in another language,
but not useful for conversing in real time - yet.
In the future I’m 100% sure that will be possible.
It’s already possible in text, with
automatically translated captions
in meeting software like Zoom and Microsoft
Teams. You can speak in your native language,
and other participants will see translated
captions of what you say in their own
native language, in real time (or in almost
real time - there’s a very slight delay).
The day will come when you will be able to speak
one language, and the other participants will
hear your voice speaking a different language
of their choice. This will happen. And you can
imagine how that will make foreign language
skills less important for getting a job.
But that’s online. When meeting people
face to face, you’ll still need to be
able to speak a common language
- or have an interpreter - RIGHT?
No, I don’t think so. A few years from
now, I think wearable devices like Meta
smart glasses or Apple Vision Pro will be
able to translate on screen in real time,
so while speaking to someone face-to-face
you’ll see translated subtitles in the
glasses. And there will probably be headsets or
earpieces that automatically translate the audio.
In the more distant future, I think humans will
have the option to have a device inside their
brain that makes them able to understand foreign
languages - so they won’t even need to wear geeky
glasses and headsets. I think this will be
a function of Neuralink devices or similar.
Let’s go over to Twitter and
ask Elon Musk what he thinks.
Sorry…X!
SO - will this kind of technology completely
kill language learning? Will people stop
learning languages (aside from their native
language)? NO, I don’t think so! Not entirely.
I think that AI translation and AI enhanced
language ability will be very useful for work,
and very useful for functional use, so people
won’t really need to learn languages to complete
tasks. Translation and interpreting in particular,
will probably no longer be career options.
But people will continue to learn languages
(a) for enjoyment, (b) to socialize,
and (c ) to gain deeper
insight into other cultures.
Take me for example. I’ve never
learned a language mainly for work,
or mainly to accomplish tasks. I’ve learned
languages because it’s fascinating to discover
how a different language works; it gives
me a deep ability to focus on one thing;
and because I enjoy talking to
people in languages I’m learning.
Think of all those times when you spoke another
language (or even made a poor attempt at it)
and the other person’s eyes lit up with
excitement, appreciation, and endearment.
They’re thrilled to hear you speak their
language. It completely breaks the ice and
creates a very memorable and special
moment between you and those people.
Do you think people will react the same
way if you’re using AI translation? No,
of course they won’t. What impresses them
and breaks the ice is the fact that you
care enough about their culture and language
to invest time and effort into learning it.
And when you genuinely learn a
language, you can learn idioms,
slang, and parts of the local dialect that make
your speech more expressive and personal. I
think AI will normally use the formal, standard
language and have trouble with dialectal speech,
with different levels of formality, and with the
way people of different ages and social groups
speak. Those subtleties are often what helps
you connect with native speakers the most,
but AI will probably not be
good at that for a long time.
So, I’m sure people will continue to learn
languages because they love having those
memorable experiences of connecting with people.
And as we learned from the failure of Google
Glass, if you walk around in public wearing geeky,
privacy-invading smart glasses, people
probably won’t walk to talk to you at all!
Some people learn languages and don’t even
speak to people in them. They use them mainly
for passive consumption, like watching the
news or movies, reading books, or whatever.
I mean, I like speaking to people (sometimes),
but I’m mainly an introvert, and there are
several languages I’ve learned in the past that
I haven’t spoken to anyone in years, like Hebrew,
Indonesian, and French. But I often listen to the
news in those languages, or read some articles,
or listen to podcasts. that kind of thing. Do I
need to? No, I could watch other news in English,
and I could listen to different podcasts. But
I enjoy it. I love the feeling of focusing
on something and forcing myself to be in the
moment so I can understand as much as possible.
So even if AI translation makes it possible
to consume that content in perfectly natural
English, I’m still going to watch it in the
original language most of the time. Honestly,
sitting back with a coffee and watching
the news in a foreign language is one
of my favorite things to do when
I have a little bit of downtime.
I also like reading ancient forms of languages
like Biblical Hebrew and Biblical Aramaic. Even
though I can read English translations,
I love the experience of deciphering the
text and figuring out what things mean. I
feel like I’m entering a time machine and
people from the past are speaking directly
to me in their ancient tongue. It’s already
completely non-essential, and I’ll continue
doing it strictly because it’s incredibly
interesting to me. AI is irrelevant
to that kind of language learning.
In short, learning languages will become more
about human connection than about functional
use. Completing tasks and functions won’t
require us to know them. But meaningful and
authentic social interaction will be enhanced
by real knowledge and use of the language.
And there will always be people who learn
languages just because they love them,
even if they don’t speak them socially
or need them for work. Think about me and
this channel - do I have any real reason
to examine the structure of Hungarian or
compare the phonology of Russian
and European Portuguese? No! I’m
just a language geek and languages are
cool. AI can’t take that away from me!
How about you? Will you still dedicate time to
learning and practicing other languages if AI
translation makes it unnecessary? Leave
your answers in the comments down below!
As always, it's time to give a big shout out
to all of the Langfocus Patreon supporters,
especially the ones whose names
appear right here on the screen.
They’re the TOP TIER Patreon supporters
so let's give them a round of applause!
If you liked this video, then
you might also like this one
right here. Just click on the thumbnail
and it’ll take you right to the video.